let's jump to the story from Tim
guest.com
12 year old kicked out of Colorado
classroom over Gadsden flag patch the
student returned to school Tuesday
saying he would sit in to protest the
school's decision this story has been
going viral all day don't tread on me on
his backpack in a viral video you can
actually hear the teacher
in this tweet from Connor boyak he says
meet 12 year old Jaden who was kicked
out of class yesterday in Colorado
Springs serving a Gadsden flag patch
which the school claims his Origins with
slavery the school's director said via
email that the patch was disruptive to
the classroom environment oh man this is
so much to talk about here uh not only
are they uh saying that the the Gadsden
flag was a symbol associated with
slavery they came out later saying
actually it was about the guns and stuff
he had on on his back and so now they're
trying to change what actually went down
because there is a what appears to be a
secret recording of what was going on it
seems that this family was well aware of
what was going to happen now of course
if he had a I don't know a communist
symbol on his back they wouldn't say
anything a lot of people have said if he
had a pride flag they'd cheer him on
well duh but if he had like an actual
communist Soviet Union flag on his bag
they would say nothing despite like I
don't know the hundred plus million
people that were killed by the Soviet
Union and if you want to count everybody
including you know uh communist China
it's uh fairly substantive I just want
to say for the guys and flag we got one
hanging in the garage and it's basically
a symbol of Independence well I mean
we're talking about a teacher right
somebody that should know this stuff she
said that this there were Origins for
you know the Civil War and slavery and
stuff this is actually had the the
Gadsden flag originated in the
Revolutionary War uh this isn't anything
this shouldn't be a shock to anybody but
we keep going back and back and back and
we're gonna we're gonna relate anything
to slavery like I I I worked in real
estate before and you know people were
we had to change the name from master
bedroom to uh to primary bedroom or
something like that it's like we keep
more and more keeps getting sucked into
this slavery talk yeah and even if it
has nothing to do with it it's crazy
yeah Darth Vader was a slave to the
emperor he called him Master plenty of
times it wasn't neither of them were
black dudes it doesn't matter like
slavery exists on Earth deal with it
even today I don't think this is
glorifying slavery this is like get off
my back let me be an independent human
this kid is what 12 so he's in like the
fourth grade seventh grade maybe I don't
know
it probably was not disruptive to any of
his classmates it's disruptive to the
teacher who decided they didn't like it
who then pulled him out of class and
said you can't be here we have to bring
your mom in I love the secret video
because the mom is clearly sticking her
cell phone into her stroller she's got
like another small child there I think
this is such a strange example of adults
having actual hysteria rather than
really monitoring what's going on in the
classroom at all they're they're once
again putting their will and their
political agenda above everything else
the question though is it cool for his
12 year old sixth grade I assume sixth
grade to going to school with guns a
shirt with guns on it that says
Revolution
is that cool I mean different schools
have different rules about that type of
stuff like whether you can like have a
shirt with a gun on it or whatever else
the the thing is he didn't they they
have this recorded video it's the gas
and flag and then they're like we've
changed our mind actually this was the
complaint in the recorded meeting
remember when the kid chewed the
Pop-Tart into the shape of a gun and he
got in trouble for it yeah yeah these
schools are psychotic it's cool like
kids used to get in trouble for you know
if you're like playing like cops and
robbers on the playground not when I was
a kid make
you get the plastic orange cap gun with
the little metal and then you get the
the roll of the red tape thing and then
and then we also had the the little caps
which were plastic uh like a plastic uh
what would you call it uh um
and then you'd put it in and close it
and it would go pop pop pop pop pop we
had those now what a kid choose a Pop
Tart and it gets kicked out of school a
kid's gotta get it's gonna keep
happening because these things these cap
guns since the the you know what the 50s
yeah they didn't have orange tips on
them for a long time exactly let's be
real high schools just have shooting
clubs
I mean it's just it's all going in One
Direction right then you see these
there's a video I just watched of a guy
in um where was he it was in California
he's walking up to his doorstep with his
keys to enter his home and guy you see
guys in masks follow him up and then
just start beating the crap out of him
and Rob him and it's just like man you
know that stuff could have happened at
any point in history but now we're
living in very dense urban areas where
these guys know they can be armed
because they don't care about the law
and you can't and this is this is we're
at schools there I I wonder if it's a
natural tendency of densely packed Urban
environments that result in this because
we had the story from uh uh sultanitson
about uh from the gulag archipelago that
you know a guy was being threatened but
with by a knife so he fought the guy and
then stabbed the the attacker got
arrested and then when he was on trial
he was like the guy was going to kill me
what should I have done and they're like
you should have run it's like so the so
when you have a criminal who's armed and
going to kill you well that's crime but
if it's you you're the good citizen you
should know better when I look at these
schools and how they're there they all
move in the same direction history is
bad I wonder if it's the average person
is docile ignorant uninterested in
worldly Affairs and just goes through
the motions and which means unless you
as a politically thinking individual
someone with passions and and and
opinions if you are not actively pushing
back defending say the Gadsden flag it
all gets erased and we are moving now
into that era where you there are videos
of people being victimized and the
victims get arrested like you know that
guy Daniel uh Penny I think his name was
in New York there's Perry and Penny I
want to confuse them we're in that
because
good men did nothing as the saying goes
and so the lazy uninterested people take
the path of least resistance now we see
it take form take the shape in police
departments the cops the cops are
looking at these mass lootings and these
robberies and they're like I can't deal
with that
so what do they do nothing but then when
you are uh you know let's say filing a
legal challenge to an election well the
cops absolutely had no problem doing
their duties to arrest Donald Trump I
saw that video when Trump was being
arraigned I don't know if a rain he was
being arrested in Georgia and the cops
are in front of and behind him and I'm
like these cops are trash they are
willing to do it it is the easiest thing
in the world hey do you want to arrest a
guy because uh you know he's got a like
he didn't pay child child support yeah
sounds easy do you want to go arrest a
guy who's an armed robber who's
threatening to murder people and
certainly now I ain't doing that and
that's where we end up and they could
okay because I mean you look at Georgia
Fulton County especially you have this
D.A this woke D.A this this George Soros
funded D.A that is you know going after
Donald Trump and and it's not even just
Donald Trump it's all these other people
you had the chair of the Georgia
Republican party which all he did was
his crime was proposing a separate set
of electors okay just in case it was
proven that uh and I I don't I don't
remember his name was David something
just in case it was you know there was
evidence that was brought forward to you
know possibly challenge the election
results in Georgia and you also had uh
fonnie Willis which I mean I'm gonna I'm
Gonna Keep with Fanny Willis because I
mean it's really funny I mean I'm going
to continue with Fanning and you know
she came out and she actually posted
after the 2020 election saying that hey
you know why is it taking so long for
these results to come out why are we
doing ballot dumps at three o'clock in
the morning even she was asking those
questions is she gonna prosecute herself
what's going on
I don't think what she did was illegal
you're allowed to question elections
right what she's doing to Trump is
constitutional yeah well she's a
hypocrite that's my point but but this
is this is where we are all of these
things are tied together
symbols of this nation's history are
being banned in schools
right they're they're since the 1619
project since before that they have been
lying about what this country is based
on what it's about and why we have these
symbols and you know what happens
I saw this tweet from I don't know this
person is some woman saying I'm so sorry
I offended you apparently she had gone
on Facebook and said puberty blockers
are a trick by pharmaceutical companies
to harm children blah blah and then it
resulted in the big backlash and she
went I'm so sorry please oh you
spineless piece of garbage come on this
is the problem how can you know that
Injustice is happening and evil is
rising and just be like I better
apologize and get on my knees for evil
just it's just it's just disgusting
they're afraid to get canceled I know
but but
they're letting evil win for their own
selfish pathetic reasons what was Martin
Luther King's quote I think is the only
what all that evil needs to succeed is
for good men to do nothing that wasn't
uh that was some really historically
that was the quote I was referencing
yeah and uh meaning that you don't have
to do good to make the world good you
just need to stop evil when you see it
or speak or call it out so that Society
the last used to be about this too Edwin
Burke I mean who was it John Lewis that
said you know get into good trouble
right what happened to that I mean it it
it you know we're talking about the
right you know calling things out
calling things out as they as they
should be you know such as you know if
you see election fraud how about you
know call it out yeah it's really weird
when you have ballots coming in and you
know by truckloads at three o'clock in
the morning okay why not question that
is that not allowed to be investigated
at this point you're going to end up in
jail because all this is now is an
intimidation tactic and people are going
to be afraid to say anything in the
future and that seems to be the goal
yeah I think it is the goal because I
don't think it's about morality of I was
like you're saying if there's election
fraud you should call it out because
that's wrong that hurts the system blah
blah blah and they're saying that's true
if it benefits our team because
everything comes down to these two
parties that have to control Power and
ultimately you know what about it so it
might actually be John Stuart Mill they
say the Edmund writer says Edmund Burke
is a false attribution because no one
really knows exactly likely but of
course the phrase the saying is the only
thing necessary for evil to try them is
for good men to do nothing and John
Stuart Mill allegedly has a quote where
he said uh where is it at bad men need
nothing more to Compass their ends than
that good men should look on and do
nothing
there you go amen
and that's that that's what bothers me
about everything these people who
would would watch the world burn
so they can sit among the ashes it's
like well I'd prefer to try and put the
fire out there's that there's a I think
it's a Sun Tzu quote it could be wrong
that evil men will burn down their
Nation their their country so that they
can rule over the ashes and weak men
will watch their Nation burn so they can
sit among the ashes for what purpose
would you I ask you citizen for what
purpose is do you have to sit among the
ashes of a fall of Fallen ruins you're
not going to survive I know that's the
thing you'll experience no joy like the
Phoenix must burn to be born again like
dude the Phoenix is a fantasy art
character you don't burn your city down
to make it better that makes no sense
it does they're not burning down their
city they're burning down your city
right your city is in opposition to
their world
so I guess if you can like sneak into a
foreign country that you hate and want
to see destroyed and then act like
you're a protester of that country and
get there to burn their own cities like
the CIA Yeah Tim who is running this
country I want your opinion on that
who's running this country at this point
because I mean Joe Biden is clearly not
running this country he's he's not
nobody's running it nobody's right so
we're no I think there's uh various and
disparate factions of powerful
individuals who are fighting over power
I think some people are more responsible
for the destruction than others but I
think ultimately
you do have Republicans you've got some
that are anti-establishment some that
are uniparty neocon establishment
you of course have powerful Democrats
their interests online in certain areas
you have the world economic forum and
their interests you have NATO
no one is controlling everything in this
nation there are just different Power
bases that influence different sectors
of the country some being more powerful
than other the most powerful block of
course is the woke establishment these
are the people that want war in Ukraine
support it and also you know want to
sterilize kids it's a weird amalgam of
people they are not the most powerful
Northern control of everything that's
exemplified by the fact that Bud Light
actually is taking a massive hit and
businesses can go under if we don't buy
their products if we were actually in a
totally centralized totalitarian state
then the woke establishment will would
be able to snap their fingers and
there's no question their beer the beer
for Bud Light is bought and anyone who
spoke up would be gulagged we're not
there yet so it still is various power
centers in the in in this country Joe
Biden does have the reins to one portion
of it
but uh I I can't say for sure I do think
it's fair to say the woke establishment
controls the most and this includes
neocons neolibs and the left but I think
they're actually losing control which is
why they're engaging in Acts of
desperate unconstitutional indictments
Etc they're going to lose the cultural
front so the only thing they can do is
Swing the hammer that they're holding
for the time being who do you think's
running the show
so I'm not I'm not exactly sure and it's
really hard to say I think that there
are uh I think you know somebody like
and I know we're we're you know getting
into really specific things here but
like Jake Sullivan you know National
Security advisor for uh Joe Biden uh he
was National Security advisor I believe
for Barack Obama as well there are a lot
of Obama holdovers there's a ton and
they keep bringing them in yeah I might
have special counsel every single one of
them has been affiliated with the Obama
Administration and so you're like okay
how did that get to that point okay you
know was it how much involvement does
Barack Obama have in the current
Administration uh because you know all
the policies seem to be you know echoing
Obama policies as well and you know I
can't help but think that this man I
mean are we actually looking at a a
third Obama term Jake Sullivan you
mentioned he as far as I know he's the
guy that Hillary sent most of the emails
to that were classified of her thirty
thousand emails or so so many of them
were cc'd to Jake just send them Jake
take a jake take it Jake I don't know
I'm supposed to have led the Afghanistan
withdrawal as well so I mean the guy is
a disaster but he is pretty much running
you have Lloyd Austin right which is
supposedly running the defense
department in reality it's Jake Sullivan
he's the one calling the shots and it's
uh it's it's it's it's scary because he
was a disaster doing the Obama
Administration he's in a he's a disaster
now so I'm glad we're calling out his
name yeah in his face because this guy
up to this point hasn't people need to
know yes Jake Sullivan no
what are you doing Jake I think that's
the thing everyone talked about when
Obama or when Biden was campaigning that
how much of this would just be the third
Obama term and did we want that right
but Biden consistently proves that his
administration is is headless right he's
not a strong leader himself I think
there's obvious signs of tension within
the administration and from what I felt
like I just said uh they the the third
white house uh council is stepping down
to be replaced with yet another person
who was in the Obama Administration so
they are falling back on an
Administration that hasn't been in power
and also
not creating any leadership among
themselves so we are not seeing
Solutions we're just seeing a scramble
to try and go back to what they might
refer to as the good old days with no
true Effectiveness it's like a rule by
Committee in the executive branch which
is where you're not supposed to have a
committee you're supposed to have a
president and the committee is Congress
you got the legislative branch for that
so we don't we don't need a committee
this pushing Biden's hands around
but they know that they have full
autonomy at this point because Joe
Biden's not hiring and firing anybody
you know they have full autonomy they
can do whatever they want to do thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time